mi chiama io il mio tipo mica lo
condivido ma ti pare
a parte che quello che gli dò io quella
non glielo dà un attimo non lo vedo che
sto parlando mica sono solo alcune voi
siete 60 e cose isola in casa già parlo
lavoro o la tessera ma vuole fare no
fa peggio per lei non potrà usufruire di
un euro di sconto all'anno vedi la gente
ricca non si placa solo per mente
signora se le interessa acquistando 6
gel igienizzanti da 667 mille litri avrà
un 1 maggio non ne vuole per ma non c'è
nessun problema michele che andrà in
giro appena di germi posso proporre
questo bagno schifo al mentolo xilitolo
3 euro neanche questo ci mancherebbe che
avete la gente che non si sa perché sono
sono lecce signora si è dimenticata
questo è un buono da due euro da
spendere la terza domenica di un mese
estivo di un anno bisestile sicuri